this is back to the barn uh man find out
some prejudice on uh that's some crystal
planets far away here which is very
interesting so this is an episode where
peridot agrees to build something to go
to the center of the earth to stop this
cluster after putting on this wonderful
presentation with Steven again any time
they're together I just love it uh so
they decide to build this ship but
pearls gonna help out build it in fact
she think she's gonna give the orders
and peridot doesn't want to do that
because back where they come from
pearls are sort of suburbian they're
they're supposed to like take orders
they're not the ones giving orders and
stuff and the idea of doing this it's
absurd so steven has the idea to have a
contest to see who is who should be in
charge and they build robots and they do
this great big contest and in the end
they have this grape it seems to be a
tie peridot doesn't want to do that so
pearl starts fighting and they start
beating the crap out of each other and
even though peridot technically wins uh
it looks like everyone still likes pearl
for any other reason cuz she came from a
place where this was not accepted and
she taught herself and you know she's
become all these great things and
finally peridot realizes okay that's it
we should work together so uh in some
respects kind of a basic story it's like
I said a lot of these prejudiced stories
even though they're important they
usually don't grab me that much but I
found this one interesting because it's
kind of a prejudice of another world I
think like when in avatar last airbender
when they had the prejudice of like you
know the waterbending wasn't taught to
women or whatever just because um that
was something I felt like even though
it's true of our history that this kind
of stuff has been done and stuff hasn't
been taught to women it was a little too
close to home like wow okay this is I've
seen this before not too close like you
know uncomfortable but like just I kind
of felt like I've heard this lesson a
lot before where with this one's a
little bit more interesting because
they're their stones and there's some
think about like how do these stones
work and in this other world it seems
like there's it's more class and I don't
know that seems to I guess that's never
not going to be a fame on either a
sexism or racism or any of that stuff
but there's something about something
about the way they did here I found more
interesting I think when you find kind
of a different point of view it suddenly
becomes more fascinating that's well the
reasons I love to kill a mockingbird
because you know we've heard that kind
of story or over and over uh but not
from a child's point of view watching it
and that character was so interesting
it's the same thing here it's these
characters that suddenly become even
more interesting learning this because I
think especially with Perl it kind of
makes more sense now why she's such a
control freak and why she wants all the
details and why she wants to be on top
of everything and stuff because she's
coming from a background where she's not
supposed to do that and she's supposed
to be what sounds like a second-class
citizen so makes sense that not only
would she want to be in control but
she's also compensating for the lack of
control that's not only has she has been
forced upon her so that was very
interesting and that it kind of adds up
even more to the character all this
stuff it's not like what's interesting
about this show is that so many of the
characters you see where they come from
and again they're sir appealing more and
more layers and it's not something where
oh well this person had just this one
thing happened so that's their entire
character Batman's parents died so
Batman yeah I mean I love Batman's all
my favorite characters I'm not trying to
simplify him but so much of him is from
that event everybody knows that one
event uh but for years you know the rest
of his development has always kept kind
of a secret nobody talked about his
stuff that wasn't interesting it's just
bear instead you get it Batman and
there's a lot truth to them the
simplicity is great but there's also
these wonderful layers that they can
reveal and stuff like that man begins
and then the anime series in stuff where
they show more and more of the character
they reveal more and more what made them
who they are and
I think that's being done here too and I
think that's very it's very well done it
was you know these are two stories now
in a row that usually they can be
screwed up so easily and it can be done
so bad and they have been done so bad
and they sound preachy and they're
annoying and repetitive but they're done
so well here and when they are done so
well you remember why people were
telling these stories to begin with you
know not just to hammer in a lesson an
important lesson but when we hear a lot
um sadly for some people it especially
my election time you figure out doesn't
sink in uh but it's still good to it's
good to tell these lessons in new ways I
think that's the important part cuz
you're gonna tell in a way you already
heard you're gonna get tired of it um I
think back in the early 90s like the big
environmental thing you know the
environments important but with Captain
Planet and Fern Gully and all these
lance rainforest movies I mean you're
just like okay got it shut up like it's
just it's not fun anymore and it's not
you feel like you don't want to learn
this stuff you don't want to help out
cuz you just want them to shut the hell
up everything that doing more of a
disservice by doing that so by finding
these new ways these smart new ways of
dealing with these lessons that are
important um I think you can make them
stick better so I think using the
characters through that these characters
that we already like and we relate to uh
makes it interesting if the first
episode just started off like this uh
you know with we don't know pearl we
don't know peridot or whatever and it
just sort of introduces us to this I did
okay whatever fine I guess you know but
because we know pearl because we know
her character suddenly it's this is a
much more interesting background this is
much more interesting backstory uh so I
liked it even though in many respects
you know it's kind of a time-waster
episode and how much did it really
further the story you know it it did
this whole episode could have been hey
let's just build a ship and it's them
building the ship you know we go you
to progress it up but I did mine the the
robot fight is fine I think the past few
episodes have been movies stories are
long so well that it's nice to take a
little bit of a break from it but uh
yeah so it's you know uh peridots right
remind me of she's remind me kind of
like a female Marvin the Martian
especially we see with the rest of the
group she's tiny she's green she's got
this big I think that's her hair I don't
think it's a helmet Baikal looks like a
helmet very Marva the margin um so yeah
trying to think anything else hmm
tell my head I can't think of anything
um just seems to be going in good
direction still you know having fun
teaching old morals new ways and still
great stuff so uh yeah keep it up and
we'll see more coming up later